in one year
Disney grossed over 2.7 billion dollars
on Avengers end game and lost 117
million dollars on Dark Phoenix and
other titles turns out the in the 2010s
not even bankable stars big marketing
campaigns or impressive CT I can
guarantee box-office success we're going
to take a look at exactly what went
wrong with some of the most expensive
movie flops of the last decade we've
drawn up a list using reported losses
from various media outlets Jupiter
ascending the problem wasn't its cast
members neither Kunis and Channing Tatum
or even the bizarre plot of a cleaning
lady with an interplanetary inheritance
it was over spending directors that were
Chows Keys have previously worked with
studio eight president Jeff robinov on
the 1999 here the matrix throw bean off
signed off on casting and production
design and approve a huge budget but
left the studio before the film's
completion fixing the effects issues
pre-release also added to the mix the
movie open to full reviews and you can
guess what happened next
named a film from the past decade
featuring anthropomorphize
shape-shifting cars and trucks you're
probably thinking of a Transformers
movie and there's a reason why you
wouldn't know the bomb monster trucks
about a high school senior who discovers
a creature that feeds on oil part of its
failure can be blamed on a lack of
on-screen talent with Luca still not
providing much of an audience draw also
in the age of successful animated
features targeting the kids market with
a live-action Cars movie that wasn't
based on their well-known Nickelodeon or
Hasbro property was a big risk
I like a good adventure I'm looking for
an adventure plan this movie not only
changed its title months before opening
but also underwent a change in director
the movie was originally titled Jack the
giant-killer which suggests that it was
planned to be a grittier edgy retelling
of Roald Dahl's Jack and the Beanstalk
it also suffered from a glut of similar
releases it came out shortly after
Jeremy Renner's Hansel and Gretel witch
hunters another child like fantasy flick
you don't eat your broccoli no broccoli
no TV Disney's animated feature sold
just six point nine million dollars in
tickets in its North America opening
weekend the plotline of a child whose
mother is taken away from him was
off-putting for family audiences as was
the unique animation style producer
Robert Zemeckis opted for motion capture
instead of hand-drawn or Pixar style of
computer animation which led to comments
about characters are natural facial
expressions being terrifying I longed
for the day that I can come back for you
and explain everything by 2015 starring
in crowd-pleasers such as lame is Rob
and the x-men franchise had to put Hugh
Jackman in a bankable position as a
leading man
but this adaptation of the classic JM
Barrie children's story Peter Pan was
criticized for its simple plot and
pantomime performances after flopping
with domestic audiences it went on to
underperform in the world's
second-largest film market China why it
was released during a summer of
competitive family-friendly films such
as French Animated Feature the little
prince and marvels ant-man poor Hugh
[Music]
King Arthur legend of the sword was
panned by critics and made just fifteen
million dollars at its opening weekend
this would be manageable for a small
budget British movie but it was the
exact opposite a Guy Ritchie directed
Warner Bros flick that cost millions so
why did it tank so bad
Idris Elba and Colin Farrell are rumored
to have turned down roles leaving Jude
Law as the only a Lister and the story
wasn't new home audiences were already
familiar with an adaptation of the King
Arthur legend starring Clive Owen which
flopped in 2004 nowadays he's the
Internet's boyfriend but in 2013 Keanu
Reeves hadn't had a hit since 2003 s The
Matrix Revolutions samurai fantasy
adventure 47 Ronin followed a string of
misses for the star such as Constantine
and The Day the Earth Stood Still the
movie's release date didn't help
competing in a December box-office
already packed with the wolf of Wall
Street The Hobbit sequel American hustle
saving mr. banks and anchorman 2 boy you
need to be a committed movie buff to
watch all those releases over the
festive period but we love you no matter
what your new producer Peter Jackson of
Lord of the Rings Fame taking on of the
loved' 7 book series by Philip Reeve
sounds like a licence to print money but
mortal engines take a crushing Leeloo
seven point five million dollars across
three thousand one hundred and three
theaters at the domestic box office
there were some obvious reasons it
flopped lack of star power confusing
narrative about cannibalistic megacities
and a woman with a mysterious destiny
but what pretty crushed it was
surprising box-office bashes of release
adjacent movies Clint Eastwood's the
mule made seventeen point five million
dollars in its opening one of the
highest ever for an Eastwood movie and
family audiences return to spider-man
into the spider-verse
which piggybacked on the superhero trend
regards there are negative movie views
and then there are the reviews that the
Lone Ranger got on its opening weekend
on paper it found it great reuniting
Johnny Depp with the team behind Pirates
of the Caribbean and adding Armie Hammer
who is a rising star thanks to the
social network the critics called this
149 dinner outing too long and clunky
The Guardian reported that the
filmmakers tried to scale down the
budget after being spooked by other
modern westerns bombing such as 2011 s
Cowboys and Aliens but a budget soon
spiraled again to the tune of 215
million dollars coming in at number one
is one of the biggest box-office flops
of all time Disney's John Carter what
really killed this one was the trailers
first was the teaser featuring a morose
cover of Arcade Fire's
my body is a cage which featured no real
action
[Music]
further trailers displayed movie as the
most generic boring blockbuster it had
no real star power and a glut of special
effects Andrew Stanton who also directed
Finding Nemo and Wooley reported the
over Road Disney marketing execs to have
the final say on the promotional
material which let's be honest was an
error
even the of Mars was ditched from the
title the movie is based on Edgar Rice
Burroughs 1917 story a princess of Mars
but just John Carter was as vague as it
was going to get critics weren't kind to
her either it went on to eventually lose
close to 224 million dollars a little
nod head to the also-rans
including Deepwater Horizon how do you
know and the promise did you go to see
any of these box-office disasters
comment below
you